welcome to 2019 welcome to the 2019
season of American politics the reality
show lots of emails from people around
the world over the new year saying happy
new year and we are watching with much
entertainment what is going on in the
country of the United States and it is
indeed a new year and I told you that
the race would get going early for the
presidency in 2020 and it has Elizabeth
Warren announcing effectively that she's
running for president except sort of not
really we're talking of course of the
Massachusetts Democratic senator
Elizabeth Warren who's been a guest on
this program at times in the past she is
announcing that she is forming a
presidential exploratory committee now
99% of the time when you publicly say
you're launching an exploratory
committee you're saying I'm running for
president launching the committee allows
you to start raising money it lets you
start hiring campaign staff that is
Senate separate from her Senate staff
every once in a while you do get someone
who launches an exploratory committee
and then never actually runs for
president saying that they explored and
what they found was that it wasn't a
good idea to run but there is every
indication that this is Elizabeth Warren
throwing her hat into the ring and
running for president in 2020 where are
Elizabeth Warren's politics in the
context of the American left in 2019 I'm
actually not going to talk about that
yet I'll talk about that in the next
segment I've told you previously that
people who would know have told me that
Bernie Sanders will be running and that
there has already been talk of whether
Bernie is at a disadvantage if he
announces that he's running after
Elizabeth Warren makes an announcement
that she's running well we're going to
find out about that if indeed Bernie
announces his candidacy of the
candidates running so far Elizabeth
Warren is by far the most prominence who
we interviewed Richard Oh Jetta
in late December interesting guy not the
most prominent by any means she is
arguably one of the most progressive I
mean I know that Oh Jed
sort of attacked the other Democrat says
not being real Democrats and I pushed
back and said well it's not clear you're
a real Democrat either if you want to
play that game you voted for Trump in
2016 but to the extent that we have an
assessment of the politics of those
running so far Elizabeth Warren is of
those who are in right now one of the
further candidates to the left but this
is going to be a long Democratic
campaign there are going to be lots of
candidates and there are people on the
Left who are responding to the reality
that there is very likely to be a large
number of Democratic candidates for 2020
there are some on the Left who are
saying no big deal the Republican Party
had 17 candidates in 2016
Trump won the voters coalesced around
Trump ultimately and Trump ended up
winning the difference is that there was
no power of incumbency factor in 2016
Obama was leaving because he was term
limited and you had two new candidates
now we have Trump the incumbent and a
really long really ugly Democratic
primary could allow Trump to slam
Democrats and to keep building support
for a much longer period of time now the
salient point that that I want to make
here is to assume that merely because
Republicans had 17 candidates in 2016
and they won that Democrats won't be
hurt by a long wild ugly primary in 2020
I think that that would be a mistake and
I think Pat that anybody who is worried
about not having enough voices on the
Democratic side number one is not going
to end up disappointed I think you are
going to have plenty of voices on the
Democratic side but number two it's
different running against an incumbent
president even one is wild and wacky and
as much of a liar as his Donald Trump
yeah and in 2016 Republicans they had
something like 17 candidates but it was
clear that one candidate stood out from
the pack like Trump was the the main
favorite during the entire candidacy
during the entire run whereas we can't
predict the same thing will happen in
2020 like maybe there'll be a few swings
and at one point Elizabeth Warren's
winning the election and another point
Bernie Sanders
winning the election and then Joe Biden
like I don't know if those swings are
gonna be entirely good for the party
there's an argument that this is
starting too early on the Democratic
side and not really I mean I told you it
would start right away in January and it
has but this is typically when you start
seeing the first exploratory committee
start that the difference is that the
talk around Warren has been going on for
long enough that this is really sort of
the launching of the campaign we know
she's been exploring for some time by
the way Warren is not the only one to
have an exploratory committee
Julian Castro former housing secretary
and former San Antonio mayor or current
San Antonio mayor I never remember he
has formed an exploratory committee
Congressman John Delaney has been
running since last year and right now
there is no obvious frontrunner some say
Bernie's the obvious frontrunner unless
Hillary runs again well neither of those
two people are running there are others
who say Biden based on early polling is
the front-runner what we have right now
is Elizabeth Warren as the most
prominent candidate as of today there's
a generational divide between the sort
of Bernie Biden aged candidates the
Warren Hillary aged candidates who are
slightly younger and then like the camel
Harris who Leon Castro younger
generation candidates I'm agnostic on
all of those characteristics as issues I
care about what is their platform what
are their policy positions and my mo for
2020 it's the first show of 2019 and I'm
telling you right now how I will choose
who I support in 2020 which candidate
most aligns with my values and political
positions that's it okay people will
write in about electability people will
write in about pragmatism what we
learned in 2016 is that calculations
about electability and pragmatism did
not serve us particularly well so what I
will be advocating for is the candidate
who most shares my values beliefs in
positions and a DNC
that is not going to put its thumb on
the scale okay that is going to be my
advocacy and I will keep you apprised as
to where I am
if everyone votes remember half of the
people don't vote and everyone votes for
the person they agree with the most
unpoliced we will be okay we would be
okay am i concerned about how elizabeth
warren is going to be attacked for the
Native American DNA fiasco for a bunch
of other stuff in her background which
we'll talk we'll talk about yes but I'm
not worrying about that right now I'm
going to evaluate the candidates on the
issues and that's what I want to look at
next with you now